[Musique]
c'est ton regard amusé et presque
espiègle et qui va dans un instant
franchement éclaté de rire c'est sa
sainteté tenzin gyatso 14ème dalaï lama
chef spirituel et temporel du tibet est
l'un des seuls des rares chefs d'état au
monde un avoir prôné ni la révolte ni la
résistance ou peuple lors de l'invasion
de son pays
c'était en 1959 depuis 23 ans le tibet
est donc occupé par la chine populaire
toutes les questions d'ordre général et
politique lui ayant par ailleurs été
déjà posée nous avons centré notre
conversation sur des thèmes
essentiellement religieuse est d'ordre
spirituel
j'ai donc tout d'abord demandé au dalaï
lama de résumer les thèmes qu'il aurait
développé au cours de la conférence
publique qu'il devait tenir à toulouse
au soir du 11 octobre octobre au couvent
des dominicains et qui a dû être annulé
pour raisons de santé
d'habitude mon message est l'importance
de l'amour et de la compassion
l'importance de bien considérer tous les
autres êtres humains au même titre que
nous mêmes et sur cette base de
développer l'amour envers ces êtres
je pense que cette claire conscience de
l'identité les différents hommes est
très important car de nos jours il ya de
très grandes différences différences de
race d'idéologie de religion ou de pays
et ces différences nous entraîne à la
haine ou ressentiment envers les autres
hommes ce qui me paraît très dangereux
quand je vais dans divers pays je ne me
considère pas comme un bassiste comme un
tibétain comme quelqu'un qui vient de
lorient je vais simplement en ne
considérant comme
et bien que parfois je ne connaissent
pas la langue de ce pays et bien qu'il y
ait certainement des différences les
relations d'homme à homme devienne
beaucoup plus proche
c'est de cette façon qu'il faut
envisager le développement d'une noble
attitude avec les autres mais cela me
paraît avoir également des raisons dans
la vie pratique elle-même
nous avons tous besoin d'autres pour
exister
nous sommes bien obligés de cohabiter
avec d'autres êtres avec d'autres
nations
et si nous dépendons tellement les eaux
des autres pourquoi nous discuter
pourquoi tous ces troubles ne vaut-il
pas mieux vivre en bonne harmonie
à ce moment là je crois que tout le
monde en bénéficierait de plus nous tous
ne désirons pas la guerre nous tous
pensons que cette guerre est nuisible
il ya peut être quelques individus tout
désir la guerre pour obtenir une
renommée ou autre chose mais à part ces
quelques individus la grande majorité
désir la paix et cette paix elle ne peut
pas être amenées par la violence par la
haine pour développer vraiment cette
paix il faut cet amour et cette
compréhension pour les autres c'est de
cette façon est de cette façon seulement
une paix véritable
peut être instauré à cet égard cette
tâche me paraît être la responsabilité
des diverses religions car bien qu'il y
ait des différences de philosophie est
également de traditions entre ses
diverses religions elles ont toutes les
mêmes bus le même but pied
l'amélioration de l'homme h majuscule en
vue de la paix et en vue d'un plus grand
bien-être et du bonheur et donc comme le
rebut est similaire je pense qu'il est
important que ces religions collaborent
en vue du développement de la paix c'est
un peu leur devoir leur responsabilité
car toute enseigne l'importance de
l'amour envers autrui
[Musique]